new york ende der 50er jahre ein junger
maler wir nennen ihn xz neu in die stadt
er malt in der art der abstrakten
expressionisten wie franz klein oder
jackson pollock doch dieser
kunstrichtung kommt bereits aus der mode
die avantgarde geht neue wege unser
junger maler ixic mit seiner kunst etwas
alt aus
so zumindest erzählt es der direktor der
kunsthalle bern new york sieht er diese
neue kunstrichtung autoren wie viel
kälte intellektueller weniger intuitiv
ist und die sich pop-art
das sind künstler die bilder des
alltäglichen aufgreifen bilder
kommerziellen kultur auch
pop art ist also der neue trend andy
warhol jasper johns
roy lichtenstein na gut dann mach ich
halt auch pop art denkt sich unser
junger maler iks als erstes bastelt er
sich gleich eine fiktive identität name
byrne blasen geboren 1936 in denver
früher autohändler kunstausbildung keine
das lustige an der tarnung sie
funktioniert von blasen hat eine
wunderbare karriere
er war bei leo castelli den wichtigsten
kunsthändler jener ära seine bilder
wurden in namhafte sammlungen
aufgenommen
sie hingen sogar im moma und wurden an
den wichtigsten ausstellung der pop art
gezeigt
drei jahre lang von 1961 bis 1964 mal
turn blassem pop art bilder 45 insgesamt
viele davon thematisieren das baldige
verschwinden die zeit die abläuft oder
bereits abgelaufen ist
hier in der serie mit den parcours
den schluss seines pop art experiments
markieren zwei stoppzeichen
dann verschwindet blossom spurlos bis
heute weiß niemand wer sich hinter dem
phantom versteckt außer ein paar
eingeweihten
sein wirklicher name ist seit 50 jahren
ein geheimnis und bis auf weiteres
möchte der künstler der übrigens noch
lebt
die so beibehalten er hat das projekt
als fiktion begonnen und dabei soll es
bleiben
der künstler liegt also noch er sei
zurzeit sogar in der schweiz sagte
direktor in bern genauer gesagt und dann
ist plötzlich dieser ältere herr in der
kunsthalle um die 80 mit amerikanischem
slang
das könnte er sein fernglas und schon
ist man mitten im verwirrspiel
schwankend zwischen einbildung und
veräppelung klar ist das eine form der
kritik aber keine hetze böse vielmehr
ein spieler macht sich ein bisschen
lustig über bord
er hat mit allen geräten mit den größten
museen das moma hatte ein bild gekauft
und als sie feststellen mussten dass
würden klasse nicht existiert wussten
sie plötzlich nicht mehr was die daten
waren das echte bilder falsche bilder
wie soll man sie betrachten welchen sinn
gegeben
das moma war überfordert
ohne klare identität des urhebers wollte
man das bild nicht mehr ausstellen
es wurde abgehängt und der phantom
künstler ging allmählich vergessen
schade findet der direktor der
kunsthalle die ungeklärte identität
byrne blassem sei genau das spannende an
diesem berg wenn man versucht diese
geschichte zu verstehen
entsteht große verwirrung und unruhe und
genau das interessiert mich das ist
etwas lebenswichtiges wenn man kunst
betrachtet es zwingt einen fragen zu
stellen was sehen wir wie so was will
die personen sagen
und was den älteren herrn betrifft noch
bevor wir ihn fragen konnten war er
schon wieder verschwunden
typisch waren blase